[Applause]
have a seat there my friend thanks for
being here thank you thank you thank you
thank you
they're screaming for you
that was all for me
embarrassing you had to be here for it
how awkward they couldn't wait til you
were gone
i got to ask you right from the top you
have got to if you could do me the honor
yes if you could show me how to do the
string dance string
we had usher we had usher on the show
just the other day and i gave him a
string dance lesson okay first what you
do if you lick the fingers
you've got to grab the string
then you grab the string here on the
side you lift and then it's like ding
ding ding ding ding
[Applause]
grab the strings yeah
that's it
hey
congratulations you're now 50 percent
less cool
good job
[Laughter]
hey uh can you show me what the bear was
doing
[Applause]
i wasn't really paying attention
maybe you could show me yeah
now things are going so well for you
yeah everything's going really well and
this is a sign that you've really made
it i believe in our society you got a
call from dunkin donuts and they offered
to name
a pastry after you a doughnut is that
right yes they offered to name a donut
after the rock that is true and then yes
yeah yeah
uh that's what that's when you know
you've actually made it man what a great
feel you know and throughout the press i
think i was doing press for the rundown
and uh in the process i said yeah i
really love donuts and dunkin donuts and
uh so i get a call from them um at the
office saying you know we'd like to name
a donut after the rock and i thought
that's cool you know you've got a lot of
things going on yeah yeah why not right
then i start to think well um
and then i started thinking of people
actually eating the doughnut right so i
think well does it look like an eclair
right right uh is it cream-filled right
you know how were they like eating the
donut and i thought nah there's just no
way yeah but unless unless
jared be interested in a rock doughnut
cozy
did you just call me conezy
[Music]
i will take you down my friend
you have to admit that there's there's i
know you think okay you're in great
shape you're the rock that you could
take me but there's a little fear in
your eye isn't there because i'm a wild
man you never know what i'd do
you never know
i'm so unpredictable as a fighter you
don't i'm an unknown quantity admit that
i know you have that x factor and that
intangible you will knock me into next
week and work my ass
there's no way all right let's pretend
that's true uh
so i think don't go for the donut it's
weird it's not it doesn't it's not good
for your image yeah oh there's a
cream-filled donut named after me you
don't want that let me ask you sorry
dunkin donuts i love your product
and you can send me some donuts if you
want um
maserati you make a good car uh
they'll buy one tomorrow in my office um
you're making a movie now i understand
you're shooting it right now where you
sing it actually this role calls for you
to sing it does it does tell us what
movie is this it's uh it's it's a comedy
with john travolta neuma thurman it's
called be cool f gary gray's directing a
very very funny movie so i play a
villainous gay bodyguard
look i can i have to do this i have to
hold my eyebrow up
i can't do it naturally i know but i
could do that but i can't do the the
hair yes
if i was a wrestler that would be my
hook you know that don't you i'd do that
and then i'd be beaten within an inch of
my life
so you said you play a gay singing
bodyguard villainous uh gay bodyguard
i'm trying to convince john to vote with
him and yeah i could sing i have i have
talent so picture me uh transforming
myself into with an afro a lot darker
goatee very tight red satin cowboy
outfit
[Applause]
and singing of all songs this song uh
it'll be over my dead body so get out
while you can because you ain't woman
enough to take my man wow that's not bad
you can pull it off yeah
so sing a map to those guys so picture
that yeah that must be a great moment
where did you step outside your body
when you were shooting that scene and
think this is really weird that i'm
doing this
yes yeah yeah
now um let me ask you about your your
family i know that you're
your father was in the wrestling
business and an entertainer yes my dad
was arrested my grandfather was right so
it's like this is in your blood that
entertaining you have a little baby girl
is that right i do yeah yeah so is she
gonna get into entertainment is she
gonna be a performer do you think uh
well you know the funny thing is i have
these these philosophical conversations
and then you'll get there i know you
have a baby girl and it's a beautiful
thing you know and she's two and a half
and i'm sitting down when we're all by
ourselves like okay baby well you know
uh you know that daddy's filming a big
movie and he's one day he's going to
show it to you and we're going to watch
it and then maybe one day you could do
big things whatever you want to do do
you understand what daddy's saying and
she's like
daddy time poo poo
daddy time
poo poo yeah yeah it's when they're 18
in saying that that you have to worry
it's when there's no evolution after
that
daddy time poo poo dude
daddy time poopoo
peeling off in a beautiful maserati now
oh with dunkin donuts yeah
in the truck with the bear um
keep bringing up the bear
i'm trying to elevate this classy show
and you keep mentioning that bear
i don't know how he gets in here um now
you're making this the movie that you're
promoting now walking tall this is uh
obviously a clap was a classic that
you've remade and uh you did this movie
with johnny knoxville yes was johnny
knoxville uh making any sort of doing
any of his stunts on the set or or
trying to pull any stunts on you was
there any of that going on well no not
really because you know then i try and
pull the stunt of of a just a just an
all day long fresh ass whooping
right that's your stunt that you can
always pull that was really funny johnny
now look at my stunt pen
you know he's a crazy guy and the whole
thing you know the jackass thing
like he he's he's a great guy and he's a
great guy and he's great in the movie
but you know some of his buddies man
those guys are crazy you know yeah i
turned on jackass one time and never got
the whole uh putting a bottle rocket in
the in the uh anus i just didn't
understand that well you just haven't
tried it my friend
don't knock it
exactly where's the time i had what
all right
uh well now let's talk about uh about
walking tall because we have a clip here
but i want to make sure people uh we set
this up appropriately people know what
the story is uh yes uh it's it's a
inspired by true story this is an
incredible story uh entertaining movie a
soldier comes home only to find that the
the town is corrupt and back of 40 years
ago it was uh it was it was uh it was
moonshine and prostitution now it's
crystal meth right and it affects his
family and um he decides to take a stand
and fight for what he firmly believes it
and he decides to walk tall okay and
this is a scene
which by the way and there's there's
nothing better especially this day and
age there's nothing fancy it's just it's
it's straight ahead no cgi no special
effects and it's just awesome right it's
not you it's it's just these are this is
just you sure
yeah exactly i'm taking a four by four
and just handing out blue collar ass
opens all right i
i think you everyone will see what
you're talking about in this clip from
walking
i'm looking for tall
[Applause]
[Music]
that's great
that's one of my favorite things
that's one of my favorite things from
action movies is that you kill like you
kill nine people with a board and then
there's still a guy who sees all that
happen and then goes now it's my turn
that's right i saw him kill nine other
people but now i'm gonna get in there
no
oh that was that was great uh walking
tall uh is in theaters now uh thanks for
for coming and bringing the rock magical
[Applause]